dans ce matin à port-au-prince un
commissariat a été pris d'assaut par les
manifestants qui se servent en maths
l'atoll mobilier divers
le bâtiment est saccagé un stock de
grenade et incendié des policiers
déserte et cherchent refuge ailleurs
depuis plusieurs jours port au prince et
d'autres villes en haïti sont en
ébullition colère des haïtiens contre la
pénurie de carburant contre la vie chère
et surtout pour exiger la démission du
président juvénal moïse
ce dernier est apparu à la télévision
pour proposer une trêve pour aussi
proposé un gouvernement d'union
nationale
mais ce discours loin d'apaiser a plutôt
envie mais les choses
l'opposition politique maintient son mot
d'ordre de manifestation de rue et de
mobilisation depuis le début des
manifestations contre 4 morts en haïti
et l'atmosphère générale de ras-le-bol
est à son paroxysme